30 to one you hit it you called it on
the show i'm
happy great my bank account's happy i'm
giving away hoodies all show you're
getting a hoodie for that you get a
hoodie
all three of you get hoodies mikey how
many hoodies you giving out today like
45
i'm not counting who knows it's time
we're all going in together my least
favorite person is someone who fades the
group chat and we have somebody here who
likes to fade the group chat
you guys are the absolute worst put some
bleeping respect on my name why are you
even in this group chat you're not even
betting and now you're gonna tell me i'm
wrong you have no
original takes get him out again i don't
want you in here get out of the group
chat goodbye
[Music]
you just joined the br bed and group
chat
we have got locks we've got hoodies to
give away
we've got an amazing day of basketball
ahead of us
i am fern that's kelly in vegas we've
got greg
ivory mikey oh it's mikey quits oh i'm
back
we are giving away hoodies all show so
keep firing your takes off in the
comments
and we've asked you on be our betting
social who's gonna score more in game
seven paul george or jamal murray
you guys have been giving some pretty
good responses so fanduel
decided to offer a head-to-head scoring
problem
just so we can benefit together all of
us have the same prop
now let's go tell us in the comments who
you think is going to go off tonight
and check vr betting social for a link
to this head-to-head prop from fanduel
who's going to hit it this starts i'm
excited this starts with the blue arrow
it starts with jamal murray
the kid is 23 years old and he's built
for this he's played
in four game sevens in the last two
years
my guy he's averaging 20 points per game
in the series because
he's being guarded by paul george and
kawhi leonard and pat bev
but on the flip side paul george
he's had a pretty good series averaging
24 points per game
but montrez harold and lou williams are
averaging 15 points per game
combined less every game so it's game
seven
those guys are going to want to be the
hero so they're going to take those
opportunities away from paul george
it's all about jamal murray in this in
this matchup and because
he's the lone canadian left in the nba
playoffs my guy has the weight there it
is all of that just to say the thing
about him being canadian i couldn't
because
i was following that that's no listen i
was waiting for it listen
kathy i'm on your side why'd you have to
throw in the canadian comment you just
pounded these guys with tons of great
info no yeah completely
he's also canadian he's also canadian
but let's let's remember he's these 23
year old legs are going to help
along with jokic carry the denver
nuggets through sorry kels continue
nope kathy's absolutely right he nailed
it look guys i've been high on the
nuggets
since basically the inception of this
show i have a nuggets at 25 to 1 to win
the western conference finals
and i am not hedging it we're going with
the nuggets tonight
that means i need jamal murray to have a
big game that means he's gonna score
more points than paul george
look look look let's not think too hard
about this one we have pg we have jamal
murray
we have jamal murray who's gonna
potentially be guarded by the call i
mean this
is game seven guys let's think about
that it will be
now my guy pg just put up 33 points last
game he knows that this is game seven he
knows that this is win or go home
pg will show up today he'll at least
drop 30.
i see him dropping more points than
jamal murray he's going to have the claw
on him it's game seven kevin
all of that all of that that's stopped
that's stopped what do you mean
no he's going to be charging the rim
right the claws like what i
do with my dog what the heck is a claw
greg
the claw is kawhi murray leonard
game seven he's going to be hounded by
pat bev by kauai
buy pg-13 i don't think he'll get any
looks off if i'm taking it over it it
might be jokic but it will not be jamal
murray
i don't think playoff p is going to do
much either i'm looking at it under in
this game
i think the defense is going to be
ratcheted up but if you had to take one
i would take paul george here i don't
like either
let's go let's go the moment is too big
for paul george
what no george is going to try and take
over
he's not going to pass he's going to
chuck that's why i'm taking paul george
it's that simple let's not overthink
this mikey what are the comments saying
people are loving jamal murray in this
bed at plus they should
hey kelly what do we call that good
value at plus 118. people think he's
going off for more than 30
d 7 dmarc775 says it's a lock at 30 plus
he gets a hoodie for that
i don't know nobody's liking pg-13 so
i'm going to fade the public and i'm
going to hammer pg-13 first time that's
right
that's right all right we posted a
ticket on social yesterday
it's from our friend at forever rich
look up
he is sitting on a nuggets championship
future ticket i don't know
he is sitting on a nuggets championship
future ticket right now there it is
he bet the nuggets on fanduel when they
were down 3-1
and he put 50 on them to win the nba
championship at plus
12 000. this bet is incredible he
currently has a 200
offer to cash out if he lets it ride he
can take home
6k here are the current odds to win the
nba championship
forever rich he needs our help he needs
your help does he cash out the sure
thing at 4-1
or does he let it ride for the big time
hammer payout
tell us what you think in the comments
kelly you've been on the nuggets since
the beginning
you might be the only person in america
or canada
with a futures bet on the nuggets how do
you play this
um okay so i never want to tell people
to take
money out of their pockets so what our
dude needs to do is decide
is that what is he going to do with that
200 or what is he going to do with that
thousand dollars or is it okay does he
like the nuggets to win tonight
does he think that he can hedge again
because that cash out's gonna go higher
throughout the western conference finals
so i think he lets it right at this
point in time
he got plus 12 000. let it go my dude 50
bucks
obviously was not a huge bet to him
so he said you know what i'll sprinkle
on the nuggets why not
i think he let it ride at least until
maybe game two
of the western conference finals kelly
i'm gonna be honest you lost me like 10
seconds
until you're into your spiel like this
doesn't even make sense to me like
there's no way the nuggets are gonna
beat the clippers tonight
there's no way if they beat the clippers
that they're going to beat the lakers
there's no way they even beat miami or
boston i don't see this happening
brother listen to me look me in my eye
because i'm talking to you
take your money and run okay take your
money and go
somewhere else go it's 200 bro go flip
it parlay it uh on sunday do something
take your money and run bro i'm telling
you
this guy has an opportunity to be a
legend imagine
you could you could say for the rest of
your life that you
had a ticket that was 120 to one
this is basically what it is and you
imagine
and you don't even have to tell people
how much you put on the wager
just the fact that you bet on something
that was a hundred and twenty to one
plus twelve thousand ride that into
eternity my g
let it ride go with the nuggets because
you know jamal murray is gonna be
scorching hot today
let's go story story over glory cabbie
i'm with you
that's what you want to be at the bar
telling people you hit this bet when
they were down three to one
and 6k might be nice too there's no way
i hope you bet this money line the last
two games
so you got a little bit rich off of it
200 that's not gonna cut it
let's let it ride and let's get glory
over
story over glory vern what do you think
about that no no no no no we're cashing
out
our rules and sports one of the rules is
that the
nuggets are the nuggets aren't winning
so you cash out
you go to the virtual casino you put it
on red or black
and then boom you've doubled up it's
better odds than taking it on the
nuggets tonight
that's your best chance to get to 400 so
that's how you play it then you cash out
or you sprinkle it on some futures some
long shots
take the money you lost you made it yeah
you made it
a good bet you made a good bet figure
out something else to do
what is he gonna do this is the question
he has to ask himself how
pissed off is he gonna be when the
nuggets beat the clippers tonight
exactly that's not happening it's just
not it's just not hurt
mike what number are we putting it on
though 23.
no nobody ever plays red black 22
is the number black 28 like 35 get out
of here with those red numbers
like 20. mikey what are the people
saying in the comments
there's a lot of back and forth here
people are saying cash out i don't think
anybody has facebook
to beat the clippers tonight and i like
your roulette strategy so i'm kind of
with the people here
i think we should cash out and get rich
on maybe a nerfy maybe a parlay
greg will let us know it's value kelly
this is what you taught us
value let's go
shout out to the people in the comments
you guys know what's up man you guys
know what's up let's go
all right we've got the eastern
conference finals starting today
boston v miami cabbie you are our local
expert
and what it's like to get beat by the
celtics so let's start oh
you just cabbie who's winning the siri
oh so you're just you're just gonna kick
a man in his fred van vliet when he's
down
if i if i was there i'd chop you in your
jason tatum's look
it was it felt like a loss for the whole
country and i don't appreciate you guys
throwing salt in the wounds in fact i'm
gonna unfollow all you guys on ig just
like the greek god did
his teammates and before you try to
break up with me i'm taking a page out
of coach santoni's book and i'm breaking
up with you guys
but with the raptors look man
look it was a it was a tough loss
and i'm i'm one of the few people that
always bets
loyally with their squad i don't know if
it's a winning strategy
but it's the strategy that i apply so
um you know what else sucks it's just
obviously it's looking at you jackals
but then tonight i gotta take g
money out to some fancy steakhouse
in las vegas as he gloats and just runs
up the bill
with his with his running up his tennie
and hennes
all night so like i'm not looking
forward to that
oh yeah we're drinking honey all night
tonight on cabbie
this is like shout out to boston look at
the dough
anti boston in every single way okay
leave the celtics
and believe anybody that rides with that
set they're a bunch of cheaters
most likely well guess what cabbie
dinner's gonna be fun tonight while
we're watching this game because
i'm rocking with the celtics let's go
i've been telling you guys
i mean they have what it takes i think
to win the east
they have jayson tatum he's a superstar
let's all
let's all just say it right now jason
tatum is a super star
he has the cast around him let me just
name a couple names
he has kimball walker he has uh marcus
smart
he has uh my guy my guy uh jayla
from cal jaylen brown exactly jaylen
brown he has the cast around him
um i do see the celtics winning this
series it's gonna be a tough one though
that miami team is
a tough tough team but uh i see the
celtics greg
miami's lost one game in the playoffs
and that was an
overtime game this team is scorching hot
bro what do you jimmy butler is
gonna eat food like boston has a chance
you sound a little salty bro just a
little bit you guys are trying to rub
salt in my eyes and my wounds
and my heart and i don't appreciate it
it's okay bro
okay hey if you're making me get the
celtics in the eastern conference finals
at minus 130 versus this heat team
before the playoffs you would have
absolutely
hammered domed that i know miami is hot
but boston should have beat the raptors
in maybe five games or six games
i'm taking boston i will shave your head
when when the clippers lose tonight i
will fly to san francisco and shave your
head
mikey about this
miami in the eastern conference finals
but i told you guys miami at 14 to 1
was going to the eastern conference
finals and no one counts
do not sleep on this heat team we told
you weeks ago
this heat team is the team to beat you
do not
step in front of the hot hand fine
boston had to go
to seven games they had no rest sure
miami's just been hanging out in the
bubble
but guess what those injuries are
getting healed they've had time to eat
good food
get good sleep this miami team is gonna
come out hot boston's gonna be tired in
game one watch
look to quote cabbie in order to be the
best you have to beat the best
that's what the boston celtics did i
don't know if you guys remember they
beat the raptors
so the celtics but the raptors weren't
the best miami beat
were the best the raptors were the
defending nba champions they were the
best
and the miami heat beat the best in 2020
which is the milwaukee bucks in a
gentleman's sweep
so we got to rock with the heat i mean
it just makes sense no no no no
so in a closed series like this you have
to look at match-ups the celtics beat
the
heat two out of three times this season
two big wins the heats one win was
really really close
i think the celtics match up well and
they go to the nba finals so i am taking
boston here mikey what are the people
saying in the comments
jamal murray goat guys stop picking on
cabbie he is right
jamal murray goat you get a hoodie
cabbie we're going to kick you out of
the group chat because i just want to
see what your reaction will be after
that
okay for real i've been following
everybody i don't break it over
you don't break up with me i'm regular
with you
get them out uh ml fresh getting a
hoodie boston in five
tatum kobe reincarnated is ready taking
over taking the over to the under drop
too fast
uh the odds are overzealous that's
interesting
we're getting you mikey for that one
that's a big word for mikey be nice
mikey what
you stumbled through that come on me a
lot to read
uh we're giving away hoodies vern the
comments are kind of slow for me today
i'm just going to fire them off stay
tuned to the end i'm going to pick like
10 people
because we're loading a little slow i
think it's my wi-fi okay all right
every point at least everyone but us is
getting rich on these same game parlays
we've been trying and we've been cooking
some up the last two shows
it hasn't gone so hot we really need
this
mikey locks really really needs this he
needs some bankroll
look at these bets people are getting so
rich
i love to see it we are not afraid to
ask for your help
we're gonna each pitch a bet for a game
seven same game parlay
and we need you to tell us in the
comments which one of us
has the worst take all right so you guys
can kick one of us out
we can scratch that from the ticket i'm
going to start here
i've got jokic over 25 and a half points
tonight because
it's game seven what's up you like i got
an answer for him i like that
i like that bet they're just the nuggets
are going to
feed him he's gonna put shots up it's
their one chance
joe kids over can we get cabbie back in
here i feel bad we were we were picking
on him
already you know i'm so bad you guys
have been mean to him all show
what's wrong i know but it was kind of
funny nice morning
hey listen okay we have to say happy
happy belated birthday to gary harris jr
and happy birthday
to coach mike malone whose birthday it
is today that's
that's in part why the nuggets are going
to win tonight i got gary harris
over nine and a half points because my
guy's been
he had a hip strain which he suffered in
the bubble but he's been playing very
consistently
had 16 points last game 10 points
tonight is gonna be a walk in the park
and with his birthday in mind he's like
this would be a great birthday present
and winning for the coach and to put
frowns on
everybody's face who's rocking with the
clippers today so
happy yeah their birthday was yesterday
no he still got that he's still got that
good juju age
but i need analytics to back that up so
it's confusing to me
he's averaging about 10 points in this
series so
10 points tonight he's got it in game
seven and he's played in a handful of
game sevens in his career too
this moment is so big for the clippers
that the nuggets
there's no pressure on these guys
cabbie you know what happened the last
time you predicted a game seven right
wow hey here we go last time there was a
game seven
jamal murray showed up against the jazz
i think that they will be
hounding him as i mentioned and we never
take the under on these i'm taking the
under
22 and a half from all i thought you're
gonna take me over come on
i'm fading myself kelly i'm fading
myself right now good
good idea all right well he needs to
pick the over for murray
because it's gonna be jokic murray oh
and
my dude michael porter jr it's going to
be the trio here kathy mentioned no
pressure
really on the nuggets here is the
clippers game
to lose i think michael porter jr is
going to be that third guy that steps
out big
for the nuggets tonight i like him over
11 and a half points kelly
i actually like that bet i actually like
that bet we
were usually on different sides but i
like it so let me give my leg of this
parlay uh i'm rocking with my guy
lou williams to go over one another yeah
well of course it's lou will it's my guy
lou willis shout out drake you know what
i mean six man
yeah you know uh but lou will i see him
hitting two threes in this game i mean
it's game seven
the dogs are gonna have to show up lou
will
is one of the dogs on the clippers team
and i think that he's gonna knock down
two
threes so let's win some money with this
one right here shout out lou will let's
go
all right let's get cabbie back in here
so we can see his
bet and people can vote on which one was
the worst
well the voting vern i hate to break it
to you i'll
i'll hold until you left okay hold it so
again
you guys save save whoever you can
pick the one we will get rid of the
parley we'll kick him out of the show
there's cabbies there's gary harris
while you are still commenting i want to
give people another chance
mikey how much money do you have left to
bet on this parlay
because you are way down do you have
enough to make a bet here
i don't know why you keep bringing this
up i will pay you back i'm gonna decline
your venmo
until i get the money back on these bets
but i i will sprinkle on the parlay
i won't completely hammer done it i am
putting everything i have tonight on the
clippers
everything you have second mortgage
inheritance sign the prenup we're going
all in on the flippers there's no way
you can sign up
you're already married i don't really
know how that works let's open that no
i'm telling you there's no way there's
zero way the clippers lose but yeah this
part light is kind of a lock too
once we kick vern out though right when
vern started
someone said just kick him out now i got
it hey if the clipper it locks if the if
the clippers lose will you shave your
locks
if the clippers will you shave your head
because i'm happy to fly to san
francisco to do it for you
oh i'm getting your tattoo you still owe
me for march too
i'll give it a tattoo from a march
but the parlors have been closed i'll
cut the man bun that i've been working
so hard on
off on the show live next week if the
clippers lose on the money line you
promise woo
more than that you gotta go you gotta go
down to the one i'll go
go no mustache too i mean i'm fine with
that but
like we just know mikey doesn't pay his
bets
that's what we're doing this is really
what we're going to do
i'm good for it kelly do you think this
is a good plan for mikey to just hammer
the clippers when he's down
he needs well i saw on twitter he had
like 35 grand to win like
a thousand dollars or something absurd
not quite all of these
jokes there's a lot of big clippers
money line bets tonight
and yes it does make me nervous i mean
look i do think that plus seven is in
play with the nuggets would i like to
see them one out right for my bet
of course it's gonna be a tough hard
fought game
just like we saw last week clippers up
double digits got lazy
guess who came storming back i think we
see a similar game seven as we saw in
game six
okay it's time mikey tell us which one
of us
is a suck bag a loser each one of us is
getting kicked out of the fairlay
kicked out of the show it's my look at
the comments do not you already know who
it is
i'm gonna tell you you already have you
have a preconceived notion
be honest you want to read the comments
do you really want me to read the
comments yes yes read the comments
you are a suck bag loser from vr mikey
locks from
z wiener 99 who's getting a hoodie vern
jokic has played too many games and
doesn't have the stamina at this point
in the season what about the last game
close to one another literally you get a
hoodie
you are out the people have spoken i'm
not speaking i'm not the one doing it
it's the people
no the game set game six that was enough
games but now that it's game seven it's
too many yeah it doesn't make
sense nathaniel sam can i let the people
talk are you done
nathaniel salmon i'll die for a br
hoodie you don't have to we got you
m week says if you die can i get it bro
send it my way you guys both get hoodies
everybody chill out we're just going to
give you guys
if i die you guys can have all of my pr
betting hoodies there you go
all right will them to you my jokic bet
is out i guess
even though mikey locks is a fraud let's
take a look at the official parlay here
thank you
there it is here's here it is gary
harris
jamal murray michael porter jr lou will
you know i'm not happy about it but
that's fine
that's fine that's the way it is so you
guys voted here
let's go let's remember who you what you
learned here today
we are betting on pg-13 versus jamal
murray
hey yes
yes cabbie i'm breaking up with i i'm
breaking up with this show i'm breaking
up with you you already did it like that
you're not going to
i'm breaking up with you guys
all right check out br betting on social
for a link to fanduel's head-to-head bet
that they made
because of your comments send good vibes
for our friend forever rachel look up
for whatever he decides if he's gonna
let that part lego
remember what is wrong about the raptors
i suck and i mess up parlays yeah if you
want a hoodie
we will dm you mikey are you giving away
more yeah i want to kind of just do a
rapid fire i feel like i didn't give
away enough people yeah go with us
give them away vern doesn't know what
he's saying
absolutely you get a hoodie for that
shotgun to call mikey and get your head
straight
i i probably should and weeks already
gave you a hoodie
will suits the comments are fire today
thanks man i'm glad you guys are having
fun
will suits you get a hoodie the rest of
you
we will be back next week after the
clippers win and after we're rich
together
fern knock the negativity off can you
send me some vibes please he said i
don't know what i'm talking about with
no see who said it
i didn't say it there was no substance
you read it he said it
i didn't say it you can barely read and
that's the one you pick all right fine
we will see you guys next week we'll
bring some better vibes
mikey i'm with you on the clippers don't
worry we are leaving the chat
let's get it
[Music]
you